join me now at Air Marshal Edward
Stringer and Edward let's talk about
that development good to see you um
President Putin given short shrift by
Ukraine when asking for this ceasefire
actually the reasoning was behind asking
for it you must have known it would
never be agreed to
well Putin has
um cloaked himself in the Robes of
patriarch kill the primate of the
Russian Orthodox Church who has made
himself very rich under Putin's rule
um the uh
uh the patriarch called for the
ceasefire and Putin has given to him it
will he will try and claim this shows he
has some moral standing but I absolutely
can see why it is viewed with great
cynicism by the ukrainians uh what
updates are we getting from the ground
about what's going on at the moment in
Ukraine
but I think to look for the story here
we've got to look behind the headlines
and the fighting still is centered uh
around bakmut and we still see waves of
Russian assaults but the waves have
fewer and fewer soldiers in we see that
the artillery support is getting less
and less and so that supports the
analysis of both Ukrainian and Western
intelligence agencies that the Russians
have here largely
culminated which is a technical military
phrase and all it means is the Russians
are running out of combat power to
achieve anything militarily significant
but go behind the headlines and in that
Ukrainian assessment buried a little bit
further down there's also their
assessment that yesterday the Russians
lost the greatest number of troops
they've lost in any one day in this
conflict 800 soldiers lost yesterday and
the Russians cannot sustain that and
that means that Putin really has to now
think about mobilizing which the
ukrainians assess that the Russians
might start today with their next
mobilization politically very difficult
for Putin for reasons that we've that we
have covered before but also if he's
running out of ammunition even to
sustain that relatively small operation
around back much where is the material
where are the experienced officers where
are the experienced ncos going to come
from to allow Putin to mobilize and to
produce an army that's going to achieve
any more than the forces are or are not
currently so you're behind the headlines
this looks to me you know very much like
Russia is unable to use its Armed Forces
to achieve what it wishes to do on the
battlefield behind the headlines behind
the fighting there are ukrainians trying
to live and work in amongst this which
is so hard to get your head around but
there have been new figures released
about
um the economy of the country showing
that it shrunk by more than 30 percent
because of the war and what's your
analysis of of that figure
what was getting headline 30 sounds
Dreadful doesn't it we look at our own
our own economy at the moment but once
again go behind the headlines well it's
not surprising the economy shrunk and if
you look at one or two main areas of the
uh of the economy Ukraine's second
biggest producer of grade in Europe
which it exports through Odessa and
across the Black Sea normally in any
year 50 million tons of grain last year
down to a quarter of that a lot of the
heavy industry supports the domestic
economy in the East well obviously that
that's that's been ravaged but on the
plus side and and we see Mary Apple here
bringing it symptomatic of that large uh
heavy industry but we also see a
burgeoning tech sector in Ukraine and
all but four percent of the companies
grew last year and are expecting to grow
so actually look behind the headline of
30 go back to the start of this war and
most uh International
forecasters economic forecasters said if
this war goes on then you can expect to
see a 45 to 50 reduction in Ukrainian
economy so 30 percent shows the
ukrainians have been a lot more
resilient than everyone gave them credit
for so put those answer to your two
questions together the Ukrainian is
doing better on the battlefield Russian
threats of mobilization looking Hollow
the Ukrainian economy holding up better
you can see why Western politicians now
might be minded ever more to support
Ukraine so tie those two together and it
might explain why president macron and
France has come out today and so for the
first time he's going to provide armored
fighting vehicles to Ukraine and in the
Tweet supporting that he actually used
the phrase Ukrainian Victory these I
think are indicative of the way the
Strategic battle is going okay really
good um to hear from you Edward thank
you very much Edwards you're there with
analysis on the situation in Ukraine